il était persuadé que je travaillais pas
suffisamment bien donc que je mettais
pas suffisamment de volonté parce que
pour lui quand on veut on peut et donc
il me répétait souvent je t'aurais tu en
crèveras mais je t'aurais
nous accueillons notre invité du samedi
20h ce soir Céline Raphaël bonsoir
alors aujourd'hui en France deux enfants
meurent chaque jour des suites directes
de la maltraitance deux par jour on ne
sait pas mais ce qu'on sait encore moins
c'est que la maltraitance touche toutes
les couches de la société même les plus
aisées vous en êtes la preuve Céline
vous nous raconterez votre histoire à
20h
[Musique]
si je rappelle rebonsoir vous publiez
chez Max Millau un témoignage intitulé
la démesure ou vous raconter la
maltraitance dont vous avez été victime
étant enfant tout ça parce que vous
aviez un don exceptionnel pour le piano
alors vous êtes né le 11 avril 1983 en
Auvergne père brillant ingénieur maire
femme au foyer au départ vous êtes une
enfant éveillée curieuse jusqu'à la
naissance de votre petite sœur qui est
une grande prématurée et là évidemment
la tension de la famille se reporte sur
votre sœur et vous vivez ça très mal
vous êtes un petit peu jalouse et
j'essayais d'accaparer un petit peu
l'attention
à votre père qui décide de vous mettre
au piano alors il fait livrer un piano à
la maison et malgré vos deux ans et demi
ils vous envoient une professeure madame
Lévy qui est plutôt une gentille
personne qui met des gommettes de
couleur sur les partitions qui vous
donnent des bonbons à la fin des des
leçons et à la maison donc le piano ça
devient une heure par jour à l'âge de
trois ans le temps est très vite
augmenté alors je vais avoir 5 ans quand
votre famille déménage en Allemagne là
la madame tonnelle est beaucoup plus
martial
qui avait vraiment la mentalité de
l'Europe de l'Est où il faut vraiment
pousser pour réussir
alors elle est rapidement éblouie par
votre dextérité et elle répète à votre
père qu'il ne faut surtout pas gâcher
votre votre talent et là votre père
devient un véritable tyran tais-toi et
joue devient son refrain favori partir
du moment où je me mettais au piano ce
que je faisais fallait que je le fasse
parfaitement et de là à commencer à se
mettre en place tout un système de
punition de du coup il vous fait jouer
du piano quatre heures par jour et puis
un dimanche matin votre père vous dit je
te préviens je te note si tu fais plus
de trois fautes sans t'arrêter pour te
corriger tu auras trois coups de
ceinture évidemment à la première faute
vous perdez vos moyens et vous en faites
deux autres et à ce moment-là votre père
vous dit baisse ton pantalon penche-toi
en avant les mains à plat sur le bureau
et il commence à vous donner des coups
de ceinture
ça a été le début d'un rituel qui a duré
10 ans et il y avait plus besoin de
parler quoi je savais je j'avais fait
trois fautes je m'étais pas arrêté je
savais que il fallait que je me lève que
je me penche sur le bureau que je baisse
mon pantalon et lui dégrader sa ceinture
et c'est tout était dans le silence
alors quand votre mère frappe à la porte
en disant mais vous venez manger votre
père dit NON NON Céline ne mange pas non
j'avais pas j'avais pas bien assez bien
joué pour avoir le secret village à vous
le supplier de vous laisser aller manger
à quatre pattes vous humilier devant lui
mais il reste inflexible
donc désormais vous vivez dans
l'angoisse d'être à nouveau frappé et
alors ce qui est très étonnant dans
cette histoire c'est que votre mère
finalement réagit très peu pas du tout
je pense que ça a été un rituel qui
s'est mis en place très progressivement
et je pense qu'elle a pas pu réagir et
les choses se sont faites de telle sorte
que on a atteint des proportions
terribles en restant finalement assez
stoïque devant la situation alors vous
venez d'avoir 6 ans quand votre famille
quitte l'Allemagne et retourne en France
voilà votre père a une très bonne
situation il est directeur il a une
voiture de fonction avec un chauffeur
évidemment vous avez une grande maison
et il fait mettre le piano dans ce qu'il
appelle la salle de jeux donc il est
réservé en fait à vous et à votre père
les autres ne viennent pas pour jouer du
piano et là votre nouveau professeur de
piano a de grandes ambitions pour vous
lui aussi
votre père vous oblige même à l'époque
donc à jouer à l'heure du déjeuner
c'est à dire que j'allais à l'école j'ai
toujours été à l'école et donc il venait
me chercher entre midi et deux on
travaillait et ensuite j'avais soit le
droit de retourner à l'école soit je
continue à travailler et si j'avais le
droit de retourner à l'école je
à peine arrivé je m'y remettais jusqu'à
minuit 1h du matin vous aviez à peine le
temps de manger voir pas le droit ma
mère avant de poser mon assiette dans la
cuisine demander d'abord à mon père si
j'avais le droit de manger ou pas si
j'avais pas le droit de manger le posez
pas mon assiette
alors à 7 ans et demi votre professeur
décide de vous inscrire à un concours
national de piano et là évidemment ça
devient l'enfer parce qu'il faut le
gagner ce concours les punitions
commencent dès la fin de la leçon chez
le prof votre père vous fait
régulièrement raser la tête pourquoi
j'étais une fille et je tenais
extrêmement à mes cheveux je rêvais
d'avoir les cheveux longs et pour lui
c'était la punition suprême que de
milliers de cette façon
un mois avant le concours votre père
décide de vous donner un coup de
ceinture par remarque noter sur la
partition du professeur ce jour là il y
avait 32 remarques 32 coûte ceinture
le jour du concours vous êtes la plus
jeune et vous obtenez le premier prix ce
qui évidemment ne va pas arranger vos
affaires
désormais réussite et tortures sont
liées mais le pire est à venir à l'école
vous essayez d'envoyer des signaux mais
l'instituteur ne comprend pas j'ai
toujours semé des petits cailloux on
voyait que je pense que je faisais une
tête de trois pieds de long mais ça n'a
jamais alerté personne parce que comme
vous l'avez dit mon père était directeur
de l'usine du village et donc ça ne
pouvait pas arriver alors tout le monde
salut votre génie en plus vous vivez
dans la plus belle maison du village
donc personne vous plaint non non les
gens considérés que ma sœur et moi on
était deux filles de Bourges qu'on
n'avait pas à se plaindre
alors là votre père commence à vous
obliger à sacrifier un petit peu l'école
il dit Céline ne sort pas de la salle de
jeux elle travaille son piano au cours
de maths et de physique parce que pour
lui c'était important mais tout ce qui
était cours de gym histoire
vous essayez de tricher quand vous êtes
enfermé dans cette salle de jeux avec le
piano vous jouez d'une main et puis vous
lisez un livre en même temps j'ai vite
appris à survivre à mon père et un jour
vous faites du roller avec un copain et
la voiture qui s'arrête au feu rouge
c'est celle de votre père
ce soir là c'est un coup par faute mais
un coup de ceinture un coup de savate et
un coup de poing j'avais vraiment
désobéi et je lui avais menti en plus
donc
à partir de là votre père ne se contente
plus de téléphoner dans l'après-midi
pour savoir si vous êtes bien en train
de bosser il met un cure-dent sur la
poignée pour voir si vous sortez à
l'extérieur comme ça forcément si
j'ouvrais la porte j'étais pas enfermée
mais si j'ouvrais la porte le cure dans
tomber c'était impossible de le remettre
alors votre prof décide alors de vous
inscrire à un concours en Allemagne plus
le concours approche évidemment en plus
la maltraitance augmente et même
interdiction d'aller aux toilettes
parfois j'avais besoin d'une pause et je
lui demandais donc pour faire cette
pause pour souffler un peu si je pouvais
aller aux toilettes et il me répondait
t'as qu'à chier par terre
qu'il enlève l'ampoule pour être sûr que
vous allez pas rallumer la lumière vous
enferme dans la cave pendant des heures
il était persuadé que je travaillais pas
suffisamment bien donc que je m'étais
pas suffisamment de volonté parce que
pour lui quand on veut on peut et donc
il me répétait souvent je t'aurais
tueras mais je t'aurais il y avait
l'impression que j'étais un peu rebelle
et il voulait briser ça alors là il
détruit non seulement vos vêtements mais
vos CD vos livres et même vous
sous-vêtements
c'est de la haine ça non c'était pour
humilié c'était pour me montrer que quoi
que je fasse il aurait le dessus
alors votre mère et votre sœur
évidemment vous laisse quelques biscuits
ou une part de pizza dans une serviette
dans votre armoire parce qu'elles
veulent quand même que vous mangiez à
chaque fois que j'avais pas le droit de
manger ma sœur me montait en cachette
sous son pull de quoi manger elle me
planquer ça dans mon armoire avec moi et
quand j'étais enfermé elle montait
régulièrement pouvoir s'il est pas
laissé des petits mots pour voir s'il y
a besoin de quelque chose ou pas alors
le pire ce sont les vacances parce que
là vous les passez carrément devant le
piano de 8h30 du matin à 23h et un jour
il décrète que ce que vous jouez
finalement c'est jamais que de la
bouillie donc il prend toute votre part
mais de l'omelette il y avait de la
salade il y avait plein de mélangent
tout ils tournent consciencieusement et
vous dit vas-y mange quoi mange ta
bouillis ce que tu fais c'est de la
bouillie donc tu mangeras comme tu joues
quand vous lui dites même le chien est
mieux très technique moi de toute façon
tu es pire qu'un chien
voilà alors le jour du concours arrive
tous les grands espoirs mondiaux du
piano sont là vous êtes la plus jeune à
nouveau vous finissez à la troisième
place et vous dites tant mieux parce
qu'en fait votre ambition c'est pas du
tout des pianistes d'être médecin
je suis arrivé à la troisième place
derrière Lang Lang qui est devenu quand
même le pianiste
vous êtes extrêmement doué mais vous
voulez pas faire pianiste
arrête de manger je vais maigrir et donc
il va peut-être se dire je fais mal ou
peut-être qu'il va se remettre en
question
vous allez jusqu'à envisager de vous
suicider de un jour vous descendez la
cuisine vous prenez un couteau bon vous
avez pas le courage de le faire mais
votre idée c'était quand même bien de
vous trancher les veines du poignet
alors quand finalement votre père
découvre que vous ne mangez plus et vous
nourrit de force
ce qui fait que votre mère et votre
soeur interviennent quand même à ce
moment-là et un jour en remplissant une
feuille de renseignement à l'école il y
a une question qui est quel est votre
secret quoi et vous écrivez je fais 45
heures de piano par semaine la prof de
français a été complètement éberluée en
lisant ça et donc elle a tout de suite
été voir l'infirmière en lui demandant
de me voir pour pour un peu débrouiller
cette histoire alors l'état de votre
père empire on peut dire le jour où il
vous traîne par les cheveux et qui vous
jettent tête première dans un escalier
là la police entre en action et votre
calvaire apparaît aux yeux de tous quoi
l'infirmière de mon lycée avait gagné ma
confiance je vais commencer à me confier
à elle et c'est vrai qu'après cet
épisode je lui ai dit ok on fait le
signalement d'accord
alors là vous êtes mis dans un service
pédiatrique ensuite dans une famille
d'accueil et ensuite dans un foyer
spécialisé il y a évidemment un procès
deux ans avec sursis c'est pas beaucoup
pour tout ce qui vous a fait quand même
je suis dit moi de mon point de vue ça a
été extrêmement important pour moi et
salutaire qu'il était reconnu coupable
et moi victime mais j'aurais eu beaucoup
de mal à supporter psychologiquement qui
sont envoyés en prison pour moi c'était
un jugement qui était le mieux quoi
alors aujourd'hui vous avez bientôt
terminé vos études vous êtes la première
en France à avoir décroché un double
cursus médecine et recherche et
aujourd'hui quand vous jouez du piano
c'est pour apaiser les souffrances des
malades et de votre entourage j'ai fait
j'ai arrêté le piano du jour au
lendemain quand j'étais placé et quand
j'ai commencé à faire ma thèse de
science j'ai travaillé je jouais un
petit peu sur le piano de l'hôpital et
des patients de soins palliatifs
m'écouter je me suis rendu compte que je
pouvais leur donner un peu de bonheur à
la seule question qu'on se pose en
écoutant votre témoignage extrêmement
bouleversant c'est pourquoi à l'époque
vous n'en avez parlé à personne
d'une part quand on est petit on on ne
sait pas que c'est pas normal on souffre
dans sa chair moi j'ai beaucoup souffert
de solitude et j'ai vécu dans la terreur
mais je savais pas que ça c'était pas
comme ça chez les autres et ensuite
quand on est suffisamment mur pour
comprendre que ça se passe pas comme ça
chez les autres on a bien trop peur de
faire du de porter du tort à sa famille
et on imagine qu'on va pas être cru
d'autant plus que voilà moi c'était d'un
milieu favorisé et les gens restent
persuadés que ça n'arrive pas dans ce
genre de milieu j'avais très peur qu'on
me croit pas j'avais peur comment elle a
pu laisser faire ça
je crois que elle était persuadée que
elle valait pas grand chose par rapport
à mon père et que si c'était elle qui
nous éduquait on ferait pas grand chose
et je pense qu'elle avait très peur
aussi que si elle partait mon père et
notre garde
alors aujourd'hui vous avez d'une
certaine façon pardonner à votre père
je lui ai pas pardonné mais j'ai un peu
compris pourquoi on en était arrivé là
mon père avait un père extrêmement
violent à tel point qu'il en est devenu
bègue
et votre mère je elle s'en veut
terriblement de rien à voir fait et elle
culpabilise chaque jour et
donc je peux pas lui en vouloir merci de
votre témoignage Céline merci beaucoup
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu